-Our first guest tonight
is an Emmy-, Grammy-,
and Academy Award-winning
musician, actor, and producer.
His book "And Then We Rise:
A Guide to Loving and Taking
Care of Self" is on sale now.
Please welcome back to the show
Common, everybody.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Welcome back.
-Peace, Seth, peace.
-I am so -- I'm so excited
to talk to you about this book.
First of all,
this is a book about wellness
and the way
you take care of yourself.
And I will say most people,
if they wrote a book
about wellness,
I would say,
"What right do you have?"
But you, of everybody
I've ever met,
always has a ton of energy
and has never
looked a day older.
If anybody should write
this book, it's you.
How did -- What gave you
the permission
to take this leap?
-You know, a lot of my friends
at dinner would always ask me,
hey, they would ask me
about what I was eating,
and they had a curiosity
that was there,
and they were like, "Why are you
choosing to eat this way?"
And then during the pandemic,
a lot of my friends
called me like,
"Man, what should I take?
Like, what can I take?"
And I'm like,
"I'm not the doctor."
I even had --
One of my best friends,
who is a doctor,
called and said,
"What's some things I could take
to stay well
during this pandemic?"
And I felt like I had
been blessed with the access
to these great doctors,
nutritionists,
integrative medicines,
therapists, trainers.
And I wanted to share
that information.
And I never took the position,
because I've come from a place
where I didn't grow up
knowing about these things.
This has been a path
and a journey for me,
so I just like sharing it.
This book is not really --
As much as I'm telling my story,
it's just about the reader.
It's about them
empowering themselves.
So I always wanted to just
meet people where they are
and not be like, "Yo,
you need to be a vegan,"
or, "You need to try
to do 12 workouts a day."
It's just about taking steps
for your life to be better.
-Absolutely.
My brother is a vegan.
And, you know, he's coming on
a few years of it now.
And I will say,
we had him for Thanksgiving.
-Yeah.
-And that was a thing.
You know, the first time
you have a loved one
who's a vegan come
to your house for a big meal,
I think, you know,
it takes a minute
to process
what exactly it means.
How did you feel
like your family was
when you laid that on them?
-Oh, man, my mother,
my grandmother,
they were looking like,
"What are you talking about?
You're not going to eat turkey?
You're not going to eat
these greens?"
Because they were so used --
My whole life, I lived that way.
So they didn't think
I was too serious about it.
But once they saw
I was serious,
my mother really, you know,
the next Thanksgiving,
'cause I couldn't eat much
that Thanksgiving,
but the next Thanksgiving,
she started working on
some vegetarian meals.
And they weren't that tasty
at that time.
But she got better.
It's like I said,
things have improved.
And people understood
that, like,
"Yo, okay, it's vegan food,
but you still can put
the soul into it,
put the heart,
put the season in."
So she's gotten there.
I mean, this past Christmas,
I mean, she cooked
some great vegan food for me.
So let me give her some love
before she talk about --
-Yes, absolutely.
Well, you've always --
you've always given your mom
a lot of love
when you're on the show.
She's, you know,
been so integral
and important to your career.
-Yeah.
-She's also working
on a book right now.
-Yeah.
-Will you be competitive
when hers come out?
-Well, you know, of course
I want my mother's book
to do well.
I want it to do great.
Maybe not better than mine.
No, I'm just kidding.
I'm just kidding.
I mean, I want her book to go --
because her book is about
educating young people
in this -- you know,
the social media age.
And she's been a teacher
her whole life.
Like, she knew she wanted
to do that at 5 years old.
So I want -- I think
it's very important
what she has to share
with people.
But I am very competitive.
I beat my mother in bowling just
over the Christmas break, too,
and I never let my daughter
win a track race,
even though she was
on the track team.
When I raced against her,
I dusted her.
[ Laughter ]
-But at some point,
you know your daughter's
going to catch up,
and I just hope
you're being a good sport now.
-Yeah, well, I keep
feeding her all this food
so maybe she still
can't beat me.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, so you're vegan.
You're just feeding her,
like, potato chips.
-Everything. Yeah.
-You've mentioned,
'cause this is not
the first book you've written,
that your mom's actually
learned some things about you
that you had never told her
but she's learned it
from the pages of your books.
-Yeah, yeah,
one of my earlier memoirs
was I revealed a lot of things
that I did as a teenager,
like sneaking girls in my room
and then them having to hide
under the bed
when my mother's
coming to the door.
And she read that book and
was like, "This is a good book,
but I can't believe you did
that stuff in my house."
There was a lot of revelations
in that book, but you know.
-I wonder if part of her was,
"I can't believe you did that,"
and another part of her was
like, "How did I never know?"
Like, "I would make
a terrible detective."
-No, she definitely would,
'cause I was a slick little guy.
I mean, I was a good guy,
but I had my slickness, too.
-Yeah, absolutely.
Very slick.
And you were always like,
"I'd like a bed that's a little
bit higher off the ground."
That's when she should've known.
She was like,
"What's going on here?"
[ Laughter ]
I want to ask
before we take a quick break
about Make One Change.
This is an initiative
you've launched.
Tell us a little bit about it.
-Yeah, it's really, like,
in support of the book
and the movement of the book,
just saying, "Man, make
one change in your life."
Like, it could be just as simple
as drinking water.
My change is, like, I want
to get more rest, you know,
and I realize how important
that is to health,
and I hadn't been doing it.
I'm doing
all these other things,
but I need to get more rest.
So it could be -- I mean,
I'm encouraging people
just because, like I said,
sometimes people think you
have to go all the way to 100
to start your journey,
but it's just one step.
One step got me
to where I am right now.
-That's a wonderful message.
I have more to ask you about.
We'll be right back with Common
after this quick break.